mich stört zwangen wenn ich jetzt auf
arbeit bin und mir gefällt es da nicht
mehr dann kann ich gehen
ich habe immer die wahl auf einer
situation herauszugehen und die kinder
nicht einfach weil man einfach rein und
das fundament märkte wirklich ganz schön
wenn ich begleite und druck machen
die klasse des dokumenten axa die
bestehenden gesetze für presse und die
auf dem ich wünsche des titels ganze
spektrum durch verlassen
märz an extreme zeigen das ganze
natürlich energie und co2 lehrer und die
stars es ist einfach ist schon oft dass
hiphop die natürliche neugier und freude
lehrerschaft lotto toto wolff dass er
deswegen gleich behandelt wird nach
individuell parallel heterogenität zur
pleite von kassen und technisch
vielleicht nur möglich hin wo die
bedürfnisse nach einrichtung betreuen
und und geburt ich glaube ja aber ich
glaub klasse bienen machen
in deutschland ist eine schule verboten
unter strafe verboten
und deshalb sind wir dann auf reisen
gegangen hat mein sohn mit sieben nicht
in die schule wollte und in südspanien
habe ich dann einen schweizer kennen
gelernt und jetzt sind wir in der
schweiz auch lisas eltern waren vom
modell homeschooling überzeugt war
dieser meinung sind ist ein bild muss
weg war
wie lang muss machen
[Musik]